the distinct pleasure of introducing my
friend and colleague Leah shaver who is
a lecture at Yale Law School and a
program director of access to knowledge
at the Yale information society project
and she is she's a yale law school
graduate in a former Fulbright Scholar
who did her work in South Africa and she
has a brand new book out called access
to knowledge in Brazil new research on
intellectual property innovation and
development and the most important thing
you need to know about Leah if I if I
may take the liberty is that today is
her birthday so happy birthday to Leah
and also thanks for all your work on
this conference and with that I will
turn it over to you Thank You Laura
welcome back to everyone welcome back to
the library 2.0 symposium hosted by the
information society project at Yale Law
School I'm Leah Schaefer and as Laura
mentioned it it is my birthday today and
my privilege I guess by way of birthday
present to introduce our third panel I
don't have any slides to make my
introduction which I suppose makes me in
Jonathan's a-train's words digitally
naked but at least I did wear my
birthday suit today now the panel is
entitled the challenge of copyright but
as the five of us put heads together in
preparation for this panel we realized
that actually that's all wrong in the
era of the library version 2 point 0
it's only possible to speak of the
challenges of copyright in the plural
and indeed our speakers will be shedding
light today on the challenges ethical
legal and logistical copyright
challenges past present and future
challenges of permissions privileges and
prerogatives and I promised the speakers
that I would keep the the biographical
information to a minimum
in order to maximize their speaking time
so I'm going to hold true to that and
without further delay welcome Laura
gassaway to the stage thank you very
much lolly
good afternoon I want to thank the ISP
and the organizers of this conference
for those of us who have worked all of
our careers on issues of libraries and
copyright and technology it's really
nice to see this moving into the
mainstream that is if we can call the
internet the mainstream I guess but
anyway it really is wonderful my job on
this panel is to provide a background
and to set the stage for our discussion
so I'm going to look historically at two
different time periods maybe three if
you count the present as a time period
first of all I'm going to look at the
1909 Copyright Act by the way which is
celebrating its 100th anniversary this
year the 1976 act and then a little bit
at the present and I'm going to use two
lenses to do that one is libraries and
and librarians and the other as faculty
members and educational institutions so
that's my job on this panel so at the
dawn of the 20th century the United
States was involved once again in
copyright revision one of the most
important doctrines that we have used
and looked at as librarians is the first
sale doctrine which jonathan zenner a
mentioned this earlier this morning in
1908 there was a case bobbs-merrill
versus Strauss which actually introduced
the doctrine and this is really the way
that libraries lind materials from its
collections so a very important doctrine
to us and so it was relatively new at
the time of the 1909 act what was
actually the big issue in 1909 was the
importation of foreign printed works in
1891 the United States had introduced a
tariff on works by us authors that were
printed abroad and the purpose was to
protect our nascent printing industry in
this country there was an exception for
libraries and other types of
institutions to this tariff but in 1909
publishers and printers sought to remove
the exception for
I breweries and so if you read any of
the debates from the 1909 act the
mention of libraries was you know the
Ala saying do not remove our exception
for importing foreign works by 1909 we
had a little bit of reason that we were
starting to talk about reproduction of
copyrighted works see I forgot my slides
I got so excited talking we had some
very early mechanical reproduction going
on but it was not much of an issue at
the time of the debate on the Act
however the photostat machine was
developed pretty quickly after that and
in 1912 the Library of Congress actually
got its first photostat machine so you
can see very quickly and under this old
act we were having to talk about the
reproduction of copyrighted works in
1935 we had the gentlemen's agreement on
reproduction by libraries for scholars
it was a fair use kind of agreement that
stayed into effect until the 1976 act
faculty under the 1909 act well they
certainly supported libraries in
opposing any band on foreign import
ations you know often the European
editions of us works had a lot of
outstanding features like some of those
beautiful Victorian graphics and so a US
publisher would strip all those out
those fripperies out and then publish a
very cheap edition and that's what they
wanted to try to force libraries to buy
and faculty didn't like that because
they wanted all of those outstanding
features they wanted the best research
materials that they could find early
mechanical reproduction didn't mean a
lot to faculty at the time of the 1909
act but by the 1920s or 30s this had
certainly begun to change and they
requested photostat copies from their
libraries and that gentleman's agreement
provided for that for them also with
faculty there were some disputes between
faculty authors and their institutions
over the ownership of
right and works but the tradition of
faculty ownership of their own creative
works was born really during that era by
the time of the 1976 Copyright Act for
the first time libraries were included
in the statute itself section 108 is the
library section this was really because
of the invention of the photocopier even
though the Act supposedly was technology
neutral and talked about reproduction it
was the photocopy copier that brought
this another thing that began to happen
was for the first time librarians really
become knowledgeable about copyright
when you have a section of the Act that
deals with your major activities it is
imperative that to carry out your duties
you become familiar with that section of
the Act we began to recognize
preservation and replacement of
materials from our collection under
certain conditions this was mentioned
actually in the act again for the first
time and we had patron operated photo
copiers at that time we didn't have much
other copy equipment although there were
some tape to tape duplicators in some
libraries and then direct copies for
users was recognized in the statute
where libraries were allowed to
reproduce one article from a periodical
issue are from another collective work
for a user simply upon their request
indirect copies through interlibrary
loan was also recognized the
interlibrary loan had been a long term
successful activity of libraries
certainly but it was recognized in the
statute for the first time and the con
to interlibrary loan guidelines were
produced by congressional Commission
that was appointed for that purpose and
these guidelines were widely adopted in
libraries in libraries that used
photocopies to satisfy interlibrary loan
request under the 1976 Act faculty
members were distributing materials now
in whole different ways to their
students
they were distributing handouts
photocopied handouts and the guidelines
on multiple copying for classroom use
were promulgated to provide some
guidelines on negotiated guidelines on
fair use we didn't like these all that
much but they were there another thing
that began to happen was the production
of course packs reproduced photocopied
materials that faculty made available
library reserves although they had been
around since about the turn of the 20th
century faculty begin to ask that photo
copies of articles be placed on reserve
for their classes rather than original
items and faculty begin to increasingly
use audio and video tapes in their
classrooms and they often wanted to
duplicate those then there were
classroom performances and display
section 110 one of the copyright act
called the classroom exemption allowed
faculty to perform those audio and video
works as well as other works but to
perform them in a face-to-face teaching
situation ownership issues continued to
be a problem the tradition of faculty
ownership continued but the question
often was asked our faculty members
employees as one of my friends who as a
university council said faculty think
they're independent contractors until
they're sued and then all of a sudden
they're employees and want us to
represent them there were certainly also
disputes with publishers over ownership
often as Ann mentioned this morning
publishers refused faculty authors the
right to even reproduce their works for
handouts for their classes much less to
put them on the web or something else
and a concerted effort to change these
transfers was undertaken with some
success not with complete success so
what is going on today well librarians
knowledge about copyright has greatly
increased I think we have worked very
hard to understand copyright and to make
sure that we are taking advantage of not
only section 108 but of fair use the
developing digital environment has
created many new issues problems
opportunities depending on your outlook
or maybe some combination of those the
Digital Millennium Copyright Act in 1998
amended several of the section 108
subsections to permit and facilitate
digital preservation and replacement
electronic reserve collections are
replacing print collections libraries
begin to use digital copying for
preservation and replacement and also to
provide interlibrary loan copies in lieu
of providing a photocopy to a faculty
member perhaps by placing them on a
password-protected web site in 2005 the
Copyright Office and the National
digital information infrastructure
planning and programs in dip it's got
the really long name I created the
section 108 study group to look at
amendments that might be needed for the
Copyright Act to help us deal with the
digital environment in a better way and
the section 108 study group made a
number of recommendations especially in
the preservation and replacement area if
these recommendations are adopted there
will be two changes that are fairly
significant to add new preservation
features to the Act allowing upfront
preservation of digital works so that
they don't have to become lost or
damaged or stolen first and also the
preservation of curated collections of
web pages not trying to replace what
roosters doing but when a library is
trying to collect web pages on a subject
matter not that the in which their
institution does not own the copyright
but wants to preserve those we're going
to see that if these recommendations are
adopted also licensed licensing has
become increasingly important often
replacing copyright as the significant
issue so what's up with faculty well
faculty knowledge about copyright has
increased somewhat not across the board
faculty are still concerned and may be
increasingly
aren't as an mentioned this morning
about the increased cost of scholarly
journals not in law but in other fields
faculty are also using digital
technologies to provide materials to
their students through course management
software like blackboard and web CT and
to post materials directly on the web
for students electronic course packs are
of being used by some colleges and
universities and faculty members are
still relatively unclear about when
permission might be needed ownership
issues are also changing more college
and universities are adopting copyright
policies that deal with modern ownership
issues there are still disputes but many
of them center on the development of
online materials for teaching and it may
be handled by contract with the faculty
member or it may simply be wrapped up in
their employment contract or for some
institutions the tradition the tradition
of faculty ownership is still there many
faculty but not all are beginning to
consider open access one of the concerns
of librarians is as an was mentioning
this morning if the faculty member has
had something in open access now needs
to remove it because a publisher won't
take it unless it's removed I thought
about the bibliographic control issues
with that having started my career as a
law cataloger there are some general
issues that are different in today's
environment authorship and ownership is
much more complicated in the digital
world than it was in the past you know
we used to know when a work was
completed and who the author was we
could identify that author what do we do
in the digital environment with
sequential authorship what about user
driven content and then we've got
creative commons which I believe Kenny
will talk about a little more but
there's certainly a number of benefits
of the creative commons licenses but
there are also some disadvantages in
that ASCAP BMI and the other performance
royalties organizations will not take on
an item that is protected under a CC
license
another good question is the first sale
doctrine available for digital works
most of us would like to say yes I'll
bet all of us on the panel would want to
say yes the register of copyrights says
no because there's something different
about the digital environment and the
last not very upbeat but the last issue
i want to mention to you is that
publishers are challenging academic
institutions and their libraries to
create new policies and the georgia
state litigation over copyright
infringement with electronic course
packs course management software and
electronic reserves is proceeding and it
is now in still in the discovery and
deposition phase i'm going to stop thank
you thank you so much lolly for that
insight into how a hundred years of
changing technologies of librarianship
have really led to changing copyright
challenges as well I think it's really
notable how the whereas 100 years ago
fair use doctrine was the the essential
provision that was doing the work to
make librarianship possible today I
think that fair use is increasingly
called upon to to play that role and
with that in mind I'm inviting Jonathan
band to come next to the podium to speak
more on this particular topic after
which we will have some time for
questions and answers and I hope you'll
line up at these microphones in the
aisles when Jonathan is finished thank
you very muchly and thank you very much
for having me here today the last time I
was in this auditorium was when I was a
student here and I was i believe i was
hearing gary hart come and this is
during his presidential candidacy and
and he was you know i remember thinking
after he was done i mean i said that guy
is going to be the next president of the
united states now i say that for two
reasons one is to let you know that I'm
you know how old I am or to give you a
rough ballpark on that but the other one
is is to suggest that that may be my
judgment is
that good and and you should take
everything i say here with a grain of
salt so what i'm going to do is talk
about fair use today and i'm basically
going to be arguing that courts are
applying fair use more broadly than ever
before and i'm going to be walking you
through some of the recent fair use
jurisprudence to make that to make that
argument and again it's sort of you know
it sort of does wrap around wrap back to
this to this building i went in 1984 i
was taking a copyright class with
Professor Steven Carter in those days he
taught copyright as I guess it's before
we found the First Amendment and and a
fair use has changed dramatically in the
25 years since I studied fair use here
and and the what flows from that is the
second point here that libraries and
educational institutions should take
advantage of this new jurisprudence and
they should take advantage of the fact
that fair use now is different from fair
use that as it was 25 years ago and i
think this also does dovetail somewhat
with jonathan's it drains point about
how others seem to be using and taking
advantage of fair use more aggressively
than libraries and educational
institutions and perhaps perhaps we all
need to get ketchup so the just took
very quickly review the section 107 of
the Copyright Act sets forth the fair
use doctrine there's the four factors
there four factors that are these are
non exclusive factors that courts are to
consider the first one of course the
purpose and character of the use and and
that has changed more recently to
focusing on the on whether the use is
transformative or not and we'll talk
more about that later the second is the
nature of the copyrighted work this this
factor has almost totally disappeared in
the recent jurisprudence third is the
amount and substantiality of the portion
used in relation to the work as a whole
we'll talk about that some and then
forth the effect of the use on the
market for the work and we'll also talk
more about that so those are the basic
four four factors and also these some of
these slides I took from a presentation
that a group of us worked on together
last year at USC so I want to give
credit to the to the other folks who
worked on this with me so the first case
I'm going to talk about is Blanche V
Coons this is a Second Circuit decision
and it involves a bland CH is a fashion
photographer Koons is an appropriations
artist or and so this is a Coon's of
painting called Niagara and somehow I
guess these women's these these you can
see the Niagara Falls in the back and
somehow the these legs are supposed to
echo something about Niagara Falls I
don't understand any of this I'm a
lawyer not an art critic but but they
and if you sort of read you read Koons
justification as to why he was doing it
again I don't understand any of it but
but but all of these all of these images
the the foot he took these these are all
images that he took from other sources
and superimposed I mean he painted them
but these are these are based on
photographs and so and these are all
high actually all photographs from from
sort of fashion photography and they
actually that was one of the that was
the inspiration it was it was an ad for
the D sandals and it was sort of the
models feet are actually on someone's
knee and this is actually takes is
photographed in an airplane and he sort
of reoriented that and and then put it
in this context so he changed its
orientation and he put it in a
completely different context so he
argued it Blanche the photographer sued
him for infringement
and and coons argued that it was a fair
use and the court found it was a fair
use and the court and again the Coons
got paid something like a million
dollars for painting this painting I
mean he's you know he makes a lot of
money definitely commercial in a cent in
you know against the extent you say well
what is what makes something commercial
or not commercial but but but he got
paid a lot of money for it and and but
but the court found that this was a fair
use the second case I want to briefly
talk about his perfect 10 vs amazon this
involves even though amazon was the name
the one of the named defendant this was
was actually more about google google
was providing amazon was using google's
search technology and this really has to
do if image search as you probably know
the way any search engine works the
search engine goes out and copies the
entire world wide web into its search
database and then performs the search
when you when you issue a query it
performs this the search not on the
world wide web but on the copy of the
web in the search engines database and
then it serves up responses it can be a
list of either a list of a list of
websites or if its image search it will
provide a list it will provide
thumbnails now perfect 10 was an adult
website and Google in the course of its
its its its web crawling it copied all
the images from various websites that
had copied perfect tens images now
perfect 10 then sued didn't sue those
third-party sites that had copied its
images instead it sued google google
obviously has much deeper pockets and
said that that it's that / that Google's
copying of these of these images and its
display of these images these thumbnails
was was an infringement Google responded
and said it was a fair use and after I
mean there's other issues involved but
but ultimately the Ninth Circuit agreed
with Google that that it's it's
display of these thumbnail images was a
fair use the third case i want to
mention is the bill graham archives case
this involved this is a second sir the
Second Circuit case again this case
involved Bill Graham archives is owns
the copyrights for a lot of the Grateful
Dead a lot of the Grateful Dead posters
and apparently I don't I guess I was
alive at the time but I really wasn't
all part of the Dead movement but there
were whenever there was a dead Grateful
Dead concert they would put out a
special poster that would advertise that
concert and then what what someone else
was doing more recently as they wanted
to put together a coffee table book
about the history of the Grateful Dead
and what they did is is they wanted to
include they had a timeline and you can
see the timeline at the bottom of this
photograph and what they're doing is is
there including for every concert they
include a thumbnail a small image of the
poster that went along with that concert
so they actually licensed several of
them but you can see here here is this
this poster was not a lot what it was
one of the unlicensed posters because
different people own different posters
are able to get the licenses for some
they weren't able to get the licenses
for others they use them anyway and and
Bill Graham archives that owned the few
of these posters sued for infringement
and and the the publisher defended
against saying was a fair use to use
these posters and the court again agreed
that that that it was a farias here
again is another one of these posters
the third the fourth case is when I
mentioned briefly in passing is the the
Google of the library project case that
would have been the fair use case to end
all fair use cases all these other cases
will look that involved Oh basically one
plaintiff who is suing over the use of a
few images of course
you know in the library project case
we're dealing with class action a class
action involving millions and millions
of works and so it really was sort of a
it was a fair use case of biblical
proportions but because the parties
settled and that'll be talk more about
in the next session we don't have a
resolution of the fair use issues there
another case that actually got a lot of
attention was the Harry Potter lexicon
case now in all the cases that I've
mentioned on the first three cases the
the defendant one in the in the library
project case the the there was a
settlement in in the lexicon case the
the defendant actually lost but if you
look at the judges rationale and you
sort of drill down into his analysis he
basically says well a lot of the uses
that one would typically make an Alexa
con would be fair uses he just felt that
in this under this very specific facts
of this case the fellow who put the
lexicon together just crossed the line
and again if you look through the fact
is the conclusion actually makes sense
and in many ways reads as a very pro
fair use decision again if you drill
into the facts now again who knows if
those really are the facts and that's
the wonderful thing about cases is a lot
of times the facts presented in the case
have no relationship to reality but
that's because these decisions are
actually works of abaca the advocacy
from district courts up to the appellate
court to prevent them from being
overturned and and so they often you
know recharacterize the facts and very
helpful ways to the to the decision that
is reached another thing that needs to
be remembered in any discussion of fair
use especially in the educational
context is two additional two additional
points first of all as many of you know
there is a state sovereign immunity for
public institutions so that means that
for if you're a public library public
institution in the University of
Connecticut library for example that
that the library cannot be held for
damages
uh under the state sovereign immunity
doctrine another factor that that
libraries need to bear in mind is a
provision of the statutory damages
provision of 504 section 504 c that says
that there's a remission of statutory
damages for libraries and educational
institution when the infringer believed
and had reasonable grounds for believing
that his or her use of the copyrighted
use was a fair use under section 107 now
I I think I've done a lot of counseling
over the years and this is a provision
that a lot of times just just gets
overlooked that people don't bear in
mind that again if you're a library and
nonprofit library or educational
institution if you have a good faith
belief of fair use then then even this
thread of statutory damages is something
you don't have to worry about so so what
does all this mean in terms of you know
sort of you know going forward I think
you know in the three decision three
Circuit Court decisions where there was
a decision favorable to the to the
defendants those uses all involved
commercial uses and so given the nature
of the first the first factor that would
seem that that if in those cases there
was an outcome for the for the defendant
in a commercial case then that would
suggest that non commercial users a for
sure I would be able to argue fair use
the second point that's worth bearing in
mind in all those cases there was in
essence wholesale copying maybe they
copied the whole work nonetheless that
work that that use was found to be
transformative because the work was
repurposed it was recontextualized so
the the courts have been putting this
additional emphasis on transformation
but transformation doesn't really mean
sort of changing the the work itself it
means putting the work in a new context
and and that is also very important
change and a liberating change i would
suggest also in these cases the amount
used was not seen rel
and also the impact on a licensing
market was not seen relevant because it
was a transformative use and so we use
her but again you sort of look at those
cases in these discs emergencies
commercial cases where there was copying
of entire works and and in some cases
there was a market there was a licensing
market maybe not a perfectly functioning
licensing market but and let's say in
the a Blanche in theory would license
what was with license or image for
example in the Blanche ricans case so
all that suggests that that again taught
that fair use is being transformed in
this sense and so what that suggests to
me is a just a couple of quick things
and I'll wrap up first that that we
really can use fair use very
aggressively and and in many instances
perhaps we can rely more on fair use
than we can on legislative reform
whether it's you know in the orphan
works context or in the section one away
second is that a lot of the kinds of
uses that that libraries are likely to
make let's say for ira's oeuvres you
know I think we can we can be looking at
that differently especially when we're
using works that are not specifically
targeted at the educational market for
example things that aren't textbooks
again it suggests to me that if we focus
on fair use being you know that the
transformative factor of fair use really
relies on the repurposing that really
can broaden significantly what we're
able to do now of course you still have
to deal with the fact that that an
institution it's very well and good for
them to say will rely on fair use but
they still need to know that they might
have to face litigation and and so there
is this this they need to even even if
they ultimately will rely on fair use or
they will prevail on fair use or they'll
rely on the remission of damages
provision I mentioned so that they don't
really have to face large statutory
damages they still need to accept the
fact that there there might be
litigation costs and and and certainly
Google for example has been perfectly
willing to bear those costs and has been
very aggressive and been pushing the
envelope obviously
educational institutions don't have that
amount of cash on hand and maybe the
answer is some kind of fair use legal
defense fund that maybe Google or others
can can fund that we already have those
to some extent the Electronic Frontier
Foundation often takes on these cases
you have various legal clinics and
finally you also have the fair use
project at Stanford but that that's also
something that that that the library
community should perhaps be thinking
more about to make sure that fair use is
asserted vigorously in people feel
comfortable knowing that there's someone
out there to defend them in the event of
an infringement suit thank you very much
so please come up to the microphones you
can put your questions to the members of
the panel of course all four members of
all four panelists are invited to
comment pull those microphones close to
you so that we can hear you really well
in the video we'll take a couple of
questions together at the beginning and
then allow the panelists a chance to to
answer them all together thank you
please could anyone on the panel talk a
little bit our for a moment or so on the
Georgia State case and the attempt to
redefine and constrain fair use that's
in the complaint for that case i guess
i'm not i'm not quite sure what you mean
about the attempt to constrain fair use
that you mean because of the publisher
sue yes the poster so does the market
exhaustion as fair use being the what
you do when there's nothing else no
other way to buy something yeah that
case doesn't exactly talk about when
there's no other way to buy it I mean
it's really looking at to a large extent
the fact that publishers had been
receiving royalties for course packs and
all of a sudden the royalties nearly
dried up but the material was still
being used but now used electronically
so I don't I guess I'm not quite
following right no but but also also in
the georgia and georgia state case i
mean
the publishers did sue over the
electronic reserves at at Georgia State
and and they have been previously there
had been sort of saber rattling with
respect and cease and desist letters
sent to a variety of other educational
institutions and now a couple of
responses first of all first of all
there's no judgment in the Georgia State
case so we don't know how a court will
rule whether or not what Georgia State
did is or is not fair use but the second
issue is again you have to in any of
these case you really need to look at
the facts and and and it's it's a and
again I don't know what the facts really
in the Georgia State case are but i do
know by looking at the complaint the the
facts as alleged are you no are you no I
seem on their surface to be somewhat
favorable to the publishers not
obviously those are the facts are going
to allege but but just a couple of
examples first of all the policy that
Georgia are the three points I want to
make one's about that first of all the
policy that Georgia State was operating
on sort of explicitly said well you can
copy up to twenty percent of a work and
that's a fair use well that's kind of a
hard thing to that's a pretty high
amount to put in writing second second
is is that they gave example the
publishers gave examples in the
complaint of several several instances
where you know five or six chapters out
of a book totaling 150 200 pages were
copied well that's a lot of a book again
you know that might be you know too much
and another thing is is originally what
the publishers allege is that nothing
was password protected nothing there was
no technological protection this was on
the open web anyone in the world would
be able was able to access all this
content so again though if you look at
those facts that that is you know
suggest that maybe maybe you know maybe
that might be beyond fair use if those
facts as alleged are true but that means
different
there are different set of facts could
could yield a very different analysis
let me say one other thing Georgia State
I mean the Georgia Board of Regents has
now adopted a new policy that doesn't
have those numbers in them but I
understand that there it is still not
acceptable to the publishers the new one
and it's on the website at the Georgia
State University